[Musique]
deux jours maintenant que le dash répète
ces largages d'eau et de retardateurs
sur les incendies qui ravagent la forêt
du maïdo soutenu par cinq hélicoptères
les appuis aériens permettent aux
pompiers de fixer le feu sur la zone sud
du maïdo d intervention rendue possible
en partie grâce aux accès mobiles et aux
points d'eau disponible de ces dernières
années eh bien on a réalisé des
équipements notamment des retenues d'eau
qui peut être ne sont pas suffisantes
mais il ya eu des retenues d'eau qu'il y
avait aussi donc les réalisations de
mahdia de pare feu à l'intérieur de la
zone de forêt quoi permettre au
personnel de circuler
90 pompiers sont mobilisés en permanence
sur ces feux appuyé par 18 engins
incendie 200 hectares sont déjà partis
en fumée
principalement au cours de la nuit
dernière suite au fort vent qui a balayé
la zone depuis ce matin le feu a
traversé la route forestière et menace
la forêt primaire actuellement on a
effectivement une menace pour la forêt
de caméras et notamment des jeunes
tamarinier qui et qui est située sur le
sur le secteur nord et on met un maximum
de moyens sur cher ce secteur pour
empêcher tout risque de propagation
mais comme je vous dis on croise les
doigts et tout va dépendre de la météo
pour prévenir la reprise des feux et
protéger la forêt de tamarins les zones
est et nord sont arrosés constamment par
les pompiers
des moyens supplémentaires doivent venir
compléter les forces en présence tu es
vraiment tout le travail qui est mené
par le dash et par les cinq hélicoptères
qui sont parlées d'eau qui sont
mobilisés il y en a trois de plus qui
vont rejoindre la flotte opérationnelle
actuelle je suis bien sûr en lien avec
le ministère de l'intérieur pour évaluer
l'opportunité de projection dvd d'un
deuxième dash nous évaluons aussi
l'opportunité de projeter du retardant
depuis la
la métropole en 2010 3500 hectares de
végétation ont été détruits par les
flammes
une catastrophe écologique que les
hommes du feu sur le terrain tentent une
nouvelle fois d'éviter
[Musique]